well we gotta check in with dayton all
right he's he's been he's had a lot
going on
as we all know if to catch up if you
want there's a there's an entire
playlist that was made on the rotc clips
channel the whole dayton hypernova saga
from beginning to end there's an entire
playlist if you want to catch up and see
who this guy is if you're new to dayton
hypernova that's the best way to figure
it out
uh this is not it this is him so he's
been posting stuff on his facebook
as kate paradoxa
uh um okay i'm most likely getting my
old video diaries of my
phobic home life set to monetization
that were listed for public viewability
so pretty much almost everything i
posted from the end of 2015 to the
summer of 2019
will have commercials on them and i'll
still learn money from them because
those videos are still going viral i
wonder why people are still watching
those videos
are still going viral when i never read
comments from any of the random right
wing
on youtube nor the occasional support of
pro pro-lgbtq person
because the stress levels when reading
that avalanche of crumbling thought
patterns
is like wowness i don't know what that
means
i'm seriously considering printing out
all the comments section and
keeping their names unblotted and
putting those all over
their mannequin art displays like andy
warhol would
or and any data artist do
do you understand how little that would
bother
any of our like how little that would be
that would be the fight nobody would
if you wrote our mean comments with our
online aliases on the mannequins of
people we would be he'll we would be
hysterical laughing
so so he also wrote this
uh um remember this is after his brother
died
yes well sorry yes
i actually have it on record now he
burped really loudly at my bedroom door
again my
brother-in-law remember his brother's
dead so he has a new villain it's his
brother-in-law's brother-in-law now he's
gonna be the guy yeah my
big brother-in-law just walked by my
bedroom door again this time my camera
recording anything
he said outside my room he's kidding at
his
children who are upstairs with him and
my sister who was right upstairs as it
happens
and none of them have face mask on when
he burps loudly they're in a home why
would they have face mask on while
you're burping uh
it's messed up because he's so over the
top friendly and kind to my parents
every time he comes over what a piece of
[ __ ] what a piece of garbage
this brother-in-law sounds like he
sounds like a real piece of [ __ ]
probably comes up
probably like brings a dessert hey guys
i brought some pie what a [ __ ]
scumbag
he never speaks to me when he comes to
this house because you're hiding in your
room you [ __ ]
and recording him and bitching about him
to people on the internet
i need a i need a hot really
intimidating dominant girlfriend to live
here with me
put these [ __ ] in their arrogant
place away from my home
yes
i ever thought
what if you moved out and then you got a
girlfriend and then you guys
lived like together man why does his
fantasy of having a girlfriend
protect him also involve him not leaving
the home
you notice that like it's it's still
like it's not a man i wish i could get
out of here and start a new life with a
good woman it's like
i wish i could get a woman to come in
here and protect me
from my free house and free money this
guy
even even his best case scenario
fantasies involve him living in his
parents house
it's the weirdest [ __ ] this dude allowed
his skinhead brother-in-law
to beat me for looking different so many
times
fully to his awareness of it happening
and even calling 9-1-1 on me
have you ever wondered if maybe people
beat you because you're annoying and not
because you're
like i have a feeling that's what it is
i mean i want to punch you in the face
and i don't it's not i don't want to go
around hitting
people um but you could definitely get a
[ __ ] fist to face
uh so many times fully to his awareness
of it happening and even calling 9-1-1
on me
when i was on the front step crying in a
dress after the skinhead beat me again
after so many times
you're right new villain just moved
right on to it
i told you i told you it was going to be
a new villain i want to make sure that
i'm doing these in order
he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] i hate him
so this is a
brother-in-law kind to wealthy family
burps loudly
at my bedroom door has no mask on
uh so let's see this this is what he was
what he was talking about the burping
sun chips back i had to turn close
caption on
there it is
yes okay
you know approaches me or does anything
to communicate with me
this woman living in this house in the
past seven years more than the past
seven years
uh our skinhead right-wing
racist phobic older brother
who was an ex-boxer has been beating me
in this house
physically beating me too he was an
ex-boxer brother-in-law's knowledge
because i was infuriated about it i went
off about it but he
my uh brother-in-law dissociated from me
he estranged me he shunned me over
being upset about the skinhead beating
me
maybe it's you i i could possibly be you
you think of him bitching and moaning
about the
like nobody does anything but maybe it's
because you maybe
like he he he goes through life with
this like assumption that
people are supposed to just like him no
matter how little work he does
no matter how much he doesn't try to be
liked everyone should like and protect
him at all times and it's like
but you're not likable like i have there
have been times where i've watched
somebody who's likable
get away with doing something that's
wrong to somebody who's not likable
because you're not like nobody's going
to stand up for you because nobody likes
you
because you make everyone miserable
he's shutting me out and now when he
comes open
he literally burps really loudly every
time
as opposed to figuratively burping yes
he only does it at my door when he comes
over
any other time any other place in the
house
he does not burp he's respectful of the
space in the house
he's respectful of my parents as soon as
he walks by my door
he pauses and he burps really loudly
i hope he's doing it on purpose i hope
he is too i hope it's on purpose i
really do hope it's on purpose dayton
in the direction of the door and i am so
appalled at that
that is so true phobic arrogant
what does burping at your door have to
do with being
phobic no no no no no how how explain
how
because daytona
yes and they're assaulting him
with their burps i don't think that's
how it works that's a hate crime dude
hateful don't you ask convicted so
broken
not those things those things are not
true
[Laughter]
i disavow that uh sorry
shitty
that's awful that's why this stuff gets
on record because people in this family
have no regard respect or decency
towards a trans woman who's been getting
beat in the house all these years
and i don't beat anymore though it's
over the guy's dead and i love that
the answer is getting getting some
dominant girlfriend
like that's his answer is a dominant
girlfriend to protect him
but also to live like again i can't get
over the fact that his fantasies like
i'll get a dominant girlfriend to live
here at my parents house there's no
option
there's literally the idea of guilt
going off riding into the sunset with a
nice young lady isn't even a [ __ ]
option it's still we live here
i mean they've been in they've been
coming over to the house on a daily
basis
because your brother just died and
they're trying to be supportive of your
parents
which i know that first-hand information
they're those people are going over to
the house
because the parents really are suffering
and you know they lost a kid that sucks
and they lost
you know the one that wasn't as annoying
yeah that's true good point can't
imagine that imagine sherman dies and
you're like we got so we got her all now
we got her fantastic for the past
a couple of weeks now because our skin
had passed away
the skinhead in the family who was
beating me actually passed away from his
liver failure because he's drinking
liquor
on an every single day basis in this
house
you know why he's saying drinking liquor
because i have it on good authority that
uh
mr hypernova is a wino
oh it's he is he is a winner but you can
just pound wine all the
cheap shitty wine i'm sure too do you
think he's buying good stuff
yeah you think he's buying stuff with a
with a cork yeah his is all twist top
[ __ ] dog
kept drinking liquor every day for seven
plus years like a long time the whole
time you lived here
i would too if i lived with you dating
that's the problem yeah
you killed him you you you murdered him
with your annoyingness let's get that
going can we get that meme going yeah
dayton killed his brother
jesus and he passed away a couple weeks
ago from his liver failing he was in the
hospital for over a month
and then he went to hospice and died in
a matter of days i guess and you seem
really
upset about it they've been coming over
every day
to quote unquote mourn him but they're
not
it's quote unquote mourn him
he has no
decency he just doesn't like there's
just
there's no there's no humanity in this
guy
quote unquote mourn him
not unhappy they're happy that he's not
around they're happy because it's
convenient for them they've never had to
confront the situation
they've had that skin hit raising those
kids when
they bring the kids over he was
babysitting those kids
and i also have it on very good
information that sherman had a lot of
problems
he did sherman did have some issues
financially and stuff like that
but sherman was nothing but loving to
the to the kids
i actually did a little research to
people that live in in or around this
house let's put it to you that way
sherman was nothing but nice and the
kids loved him and he was really nice he
was
he was a fun drunk from from all from
all from from all the information i'm
getting is
sherman did drink but he was one of
those funny it's fun uncle sherman's
drinking again
it wasn't beat people up himself
carrying them around while he was drunk
i have that on camera
so i get all right but
[Music]
[Music]
okay
the door of my bedroom that's crazy you
can hear
that was definitely right there
that's crazy that's the second time he's
done that in a matter of days
he's not he has never communicated me
since the passing of our
brother his brother-in-law's total
skinned head racist
that's crazy what's crazy is that he
died
he died and you're just continuing this
i know what you guys were worried about
you're not lo you didn't couldn't see
him in the last video
yeah that's what i was worried about me
right now my
dad went to pick up my mom from work so
they'll be gone for a little while
because i think they're going to the
store
i think he said so anyway uh i wanted to
get on camera
um i don't know i wanted to show
my house right now because uh i
literally
in the past seven more than seven years
really um
i have barely been able to even walk
around in my own house oh my god
is it all your skin flakes is it the
skin flakes that you have on the floor
uh my skinhead older brother moved home
uh over seven years ago
uh he was an ex-boxer uh
he was a you know he hated trans women
he hated gay people
no no no he just hated you yeah you just
hate each other
and honestly like dayton is a great
example this is what sjws are
they are people who are wholly unlikable
inside and out and they the reason they
attach themselves to these sjw
causes is because it's like oh they're
picking on trans people like us
trans people and it's like no they just
hate you and that's why
you know individuality wins because it's
like being a part of a group is
i'm not going to stand up for you and
defend you when you're
a a wholly unlikable person like there's
no reason for me to have to do that
so these people all do that yeah it's
all solidarity and it's like well no
it's just you that sucks
but it's like getting mugged by a guy
named tyrone and you're going dude this
guy's a piece of [ __ ] dude he stole my
wallet
what you hate black people no no no i
just just tyrone
yeah and also yes yes i do but the point
is is this guy also took my things
he hated black people he hated uh
any racial minority or okay but he's
dead now
yeah right isn't the normal thing to do
when somebody dies
to just be like you know like you know
it wasn't perfect or whatever but you
know he's gone now
and you know you just remember him and
you move on right isn't that what normal
people do
you don't sit around and go and he was a
racist and he was a womanizer too oh and
it's like okay he's dead yeah why are we
sitting here bashing him
like an intellectual minority and
whatever
uh he really really what's an
intellectual minority
um okay
had some severely crazy
views against minority groups of any
kind he hated women he was a misogynist
but first of all he didn't hate women
and against minor he doesn't hate black
people he hung out with his black with
your black neighbor all the
time all the time second of all
women are [ __ ] women are hateful
dayton okay case in point
yeah there you go maybe maybe that's why
he's so hateable he's really leaning
into being a woman
yeah and so all of that crazy stuff he
was an ex-boxer
i think about it prosecution complex
victim complex
no job uh lays around all day and
expects to be paid to live in a house
he's a white woman a penis he's well
yeah
now good ones the keepers if you're a
lucky guy
west uh years many years and they moved
home
a little over seven years ago and he was
an alcoholic mess who
uh drank liquor why did he move home uh
earl because
because he because he'd left home yeah
so he was
returning home i see i think this entire
thing
[Music]
stems from the fact that earl
liked freeloading off of his parents he
loved living there for free
he loved having the whole run of the
place and then the brother came home
and he's got he's been like [ __ ] this
this is [ __ ] he gets to come back
and live here and he has no sense of
like
you've never left there yeah sherman
left he's coming back he's down on his
luck [ __ ] happens but like
i have a feeling that was where this
really started was he just started
becoming obsessed with like but this is
my
mind i'm supposed to be here sherman's
not supposed to be here you know and
it's just
dating so he's going to take you on a
tour of the house so
i'm going to very quickly kind of show
this is the hallway
okay um this is the uh
steps to my uh the attic
area um basically well the reason you
see the steps of the attic area
mess that's where all his [ __ ] is kept
all his dresses
all his clothes all the aluminum foil in
the dayton area
this art project with his swirls yeah
and i'll maybe i'll show more of that
later on here but
oh good good something to look forward
to
the uh look you got to put something for
the sequel [ __ ] man
that's what we call a team this is my
parents room so i'm not gonna like stick
around in here
but you're gonna go in there and film it
like regardless of how long you stay in
right yeah you're still in there filming
it
yeah i would be so uncomfortable going
into anyone's bedroom with the camera
rolling
even if they weren't home it's not about
like seeing them naked but it's like
it's awkward i'm weird about rooms it's
like don't go on something even if like
somebody's staying with me and they're
in a guest room like i'm not gonna go
like it's like once they leave whatever
you go in there and clean up but like
it's weird to me when people just do
that they just go in your [ __ ] and
you're like what like roommates and [ __ ]
where you're like
what are you doing what are you [ __ ]
doing and
filming it his parents who care for him
going into the people who pay for give
him money and let him live in the house
and when they're home when they're not
home
they gotta worry about this prick
putting videos of their bedroom up on
youtube
i'd be furious i would have killed him
so long ago
room and my mom's beautiful vanity there
it's too bad that we really don't get
along because i really admire
so leave some aspects of her style i
really admire
just move leave you know and this is
my older brother's
me i don't know why he's filming
his deadpool his dead brother's room
what is wrong with you man well how much
time do you got
uh about 15 minutes he's a stud this is
a sick guy
he removed he he
seemed to dismantle the bed in here or
whatever
before he passed away like he was in the
hospital for
an entire month before he passed away
i mean this is my bedroom in here it's
pretty much a mess so i'm not gonna
notice it out of every bedroom his is
the one that's a mess his attic is a
mess
all his stuff all his stuff is the messy
stuff come in here and
really it's what i don't get is right
like
you don't have a job so you're home
all day you're home all day
with nothing to do shouldn't you at
least have
a clean bedroom no
like you're home all day how can he
clean his bedroom when his parents are
being so
think about that for a second mike
you're right when you're right you're
right
yeah bedroom really well i guess the
guest bedroom is in here
it's slightly smaller and much cleaner
look how clean the guest bedroom is also
a bit of a mess
because yeah they're just stupid a
little bit of a mess
what a mess what a mess i guess bedroom
is it's disgusting
deplorable conditions side room
with uh it's basically an office room
there's this what's the point of touring
the house
just uh it's sort of in dia in a diary
video form uh
that uh i hope when his parents die they
order him legally out of the house and
they leave that house to the
brother-in-law and the sister
and i hope he's never allowed to set
foot in that house again
living here he's lived here he was
living here seven years
more than that more like seven hours
boxer and he's dead now
earl he's dead now no i mean i it really
is
forget about the fact that it's just in
poor taste to speak shitty of the dead
you know but on top of that like
even just to be this fixated on it
forget about the fact that you're
bashing the dead like i
i get it i'm sure you could find me
bashing dead people
because their name came up and you go
like oh [ __ ] that i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] him even if he is dead you know
what i mean like that that'll happen
but to ups like to constantly want to
talk about it and bring it up
and and and veer conversations towards
it is weird and obsessive right
well even more than that it's not like
it's a stranger it's his brother it's
your family
you know which makes it very weird to me
such a raging alcoholic mess of a man
who hates
people like all hated every minority
group imaginable
um fifty percent of the population
earlier
female question who are you
bashing him to like who who's
what what is my point is with what's the
end game here like
are we supposed to shun the dead guy are
we gonna get the dead guy fired from his
job are we gonna dox the dead guy
like he's dead there's nothing to do to
him
wow
and i'm a bit of a mess right now
because you know it's oh you
you're positively glowing yeah well no
that's the psoriasis
oh you're right it's skin is just raw
and shiny yes
it's dry and shiny it's snowing
and just i just want to get this video
real quick while no one was hum at all
what is the point
of being alive in this state
i don't know right like i i would
rather be dead than live like that i
don't see
like to have no friends to have
nobody who loves to have everyone hate
you because you're just so
unbearable and then to just he has
no job no life no social life no
girlfriend no interests
nothing like that this is his life just
hanging out sitting around in the house
all day
waiting for death like waiting for time
to just
like i never understood people who just
sit there and wait for time to pass it's
like
you know do something right even even a
video game
something do something he just exists he
just
takes up space well somebody asked and
this is a question that a few people
have asked i guess i'll answer it which
is
does there any positive comments on his
video all his videos are unlisted
so the videos only get five or six views
he only post is for his facebook friends
and post it for us basically
yeah so we're haven't in on the
obviously facebook thing but
uh or couple ends so that's why we see
the videos
he he's making these videos for nobody
these are for nobody
these are videos he's making for him and
seven other people
this is the last one i thought he was
monetized now i thought he was going to
start
no he's just monetize he's just going to
monetize his old
videos because he says they're going
viral
so this me explaining on camera my big
sister and brother-in-law exploiting a
violent skinhead passing
my sister and her husband never
associated
with anything in this house while the
skinhead was living here beating me but
they did we watched
we saw videos of them all the time they
were always over there they were overall
you were always complaining they were
here over the time
kids over for uh
the kids grandparents to be to be able
to babysit them and
they would let the skin hit babysit the
kids
you know while he was an alcoholic mess
the man would be drinking
and then picking up the small children
oh my god the unthinkable
crazy it's crazy oh happy girl lucky
that he's gone he passed away from his
alcoholism two weeks ago
that's crazy they're just coming over
being as happy as
you can even imagine and it's not even
the slightest morning about it
these were bigots but they refused to be
involved in him beating me
and they refused to interfere on any
level and now that he's gone it's
convenient for them
everybody wants to hit you yeah every i
think everyone wants to hit you
and you might be the problem you might
be the most
hittable person on the planet yeah he's
up there
like he would be he it would feel good
to hit him
yeah i feel nice right even when i hit
somebody because i'm mad or i don't like
him or whatever i don't feel good about
it
but it would feel good to hit earl
dude and i bet i still i still stand by
my theory that he probably was beaten up
by sherman once
maybe twice in situations he probably
started instigating and then it's like
well
you know you're gonna you're gonna talk
you're gonna talk that [ __ ]
he's probably well we actually saw a
video remember where the reason showman
hit him was because uh because earl
broke a wine glass over his head we saw
that on christmas
i think it was like christmas week
god awful they've been coming over all
just about
every single day in the past two weeks
after he's in celebration
of his death essentially scumbags
which would be one thing maybe if they
were against
the beatings like they were they
remained emotionally uninvolved
on any level whatsoever you're not
likable dayton
nobody's gonna get emotionally involved
with somebody like you
nobody would feel bad nobody cares how
about this
how about this right let me let's let's
try this from a different angle
earl you're absolutely right
your family is [ __ ] up
for not acknowledging the beatings for
not acknowledging your psoriasis your
need for health burritos
you need to steal their credit cards and
use it you need to live in their home
for free you need to
have them pay you for nothing you're
right your family is [ __ ] up they
don't consider your feelings
but just bear with me on this for just
one moment
have you ever in your entire life
once thought about anybody else's
feelings
like you can't [ __ ] that everybody else
is a terrible person if you're a
terrible person you're a terrible person
you don't think about the [ __ ] ogden
you give your father you don't think
about the stress you cause your mother
you don't think about
um remember the ride video
where i need a ride now i don't need a
ride well maybe i'll need a ride i don't
know if i need a ride how long is it
take you should take a shower seven
hours
dude it's one thing if if you were right
and these people
were awful and terrible but you were
just so altruistic but do
do you ever think about what they're
going through or are you
still spiraling about beatings from a
guy who's been dead for
like a week now two weeks weeks so
that's my favorite thing with people
like this they'll be like they did this
and
they're they're terrible and they just
pay balls
they're so man it's like okay have you
ever once thought like
maybe my dad wants to just relax he's
been working all week all right i'll
make it quick
we'll hop in the car we'll get this done
there's never any shred of consideration
for others
but he wants everyone to stop and
consider his feelings in everything and
it's
it's dude this is one of the worst cases
of narcissism i've ever seen
and it's you know to even to even add on
to what you're saying forget even his
family even
even like other people who get [ __ ]
annoying and they're dumb
he's never made a video even talking
about any other
person that's in trouble or any other
gay person it's only him because he
doesn't care
he's never said like oh the plight of
people can you believe that blah blah
blah blah blah blah
people are or brought up how those
people are abusing gay people are
discriminated it's not even them
to the point where the [ __ ] dayton
lgbtq club whatever you want to call it
it doesn't like him they don't like him
his own
people don't like him he's annoying
because the thing isn't even a real
identity it's just a shield
that he uses to protect himself from you
know to be
to be a special interest group to be
protected from things
yeah extra victim points so of course he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about what other
people are going through with those
problems like it's just oh he's so i've
never
we've never covered anybody more
hateable than this guy
he really is the [ __ ] worst and he's
worse than the sex pickup artists
he he's worse than all of these people
he's worse than all the political
grifters
this man is worse